*Screaming* *Moaning*
*GONE SEXUAL!!!!*
The world is coming to an end!
Have you opened your eyes yet?
Catastrophic hurricanes, record high earthquakes and insane amount of wild fires.
Makes me feel like the world is coming to and end [wtf pewds read plz]
California on fire
Oregon on fire
Montana on fire
Canada on fire
Texas underwater
Idaho 5.3 earthquake
Hurricane Irma is forming
Look at this picture
Fifteen thousand retweets. Look at this picture, my God.
It's almost like the world is ending
Except this is footage from 2014
Wow and then more than 250 firefighters
Woooow
"And then more than 250 firefighters battling these flames" The world ended 3 years ago and we didn't even notice!
THE WORLD ENDED 3 YEARS AGO AND WE DIDNT EVEN NOTICE
You know no one said it better than Sarah Silverman herself pray for Washington
You know, no one said it better than Sarah Silverman herself:
Pray for Washington
Pray for Oregon
Pray for Montana
Pray for California [thats Texas, pewds, learn your shit]
Pray for Texas [now California, y'all pray now]
Pray for Florida
Ehe
Ehe-ehe
No
No, no, no, excuse me. We do not pray. Don't pray.
Vote for a government...
...that believes in science [is math related to science?]
That's right. That's right, Washington. That's right, Washington, you should have thought twice
Washington.
Should have-you should have thought twice, Washington!
Before you started those fires
Mother Nature is real a mad, okay? I swear, Washington
You should-I bet-you should have thought twice before what vor-voting for Trump, Washington
It was caused by a teenage boy with fireworks?
No, no, no!
It was Donald Trump himself!
That was Donald Trump [wtf that is a clear proof]
Have you voted for a government that cares about the environment yet? Huh?
I also really like how this
This, this, it doesn't have Mexico on it
Suddenly Mexico isn't that important
*the states have fire = end of the world - mexico has a magnitude 8.1 earthquake = they'll be fiiiiiiinee
Sorry, it's horrible. This is horrible
I'm trying to make some comedy out of this, but it's fucking hard man
It's so disgusting to me seeing these celebrities using these natural disasters
And, you know, blaming these fires caused by
teenagers to further their political agenda
You know, whatever side of it it may be, the fact that they use this, to me.. It's so fucking gross
It's these kind of celebrities that live in a bubble
Everything is so shielded from them, they get these outrageous thought, and they don't understand how fucking.. Oh my God
'Coz clearly
hurricanes never happened before
As this picture from 2004. These hurricanes were fake hurricanes, okay, just like fake news. They were fake hurricane
The world
may have seemed like it ended before, but no
Those hurricanes don't count, okay?
Now Trump
This is Trump's fault.
Everything is Trump's fault
These hurricanes.. pff..
Are you telling me, hurricanes happening during hurricanes season?
IT MUST BE DONALD TRUMP'S FAULT!
Just listen to Jennifer Lawrence herself.
"If you can get away with paying somebody less, then do it...
...you know, a lot of people don't choose the moral...
...high road and say 'No, that's not fair'...
...
...and, I don't know, or you could go philosophical and say 'Why are we so afraid of whamen?'"
*giggle*
My fucking God, you fucking...
Yeah, no, yeah, you-you got paid, you got paid less because you have a shitty fucking agent, Jennifer.
Stop crying
"It's also scary to know...
...it's been proven through science that...
...human activity...
...that climate change is due to human activity"
It's like.. well, you fly a private jet anywhere you go, Jennifer...
"And we continue to ignoring" *great canon*
Well, she's not lying there
"The only voice that we really have is through voting..."
But what, the only thing we can do is to vote!
"So..."
"And you have voted..."
"...and we voted. And it was... really startling...
...You know, you're watching these hurricanes now, and it's really, it's hard, especially while promoting this movie not to...
...not to feel mother nature's...
...rage, wrath"
Oh my God...
Well, I guess you know, she's right
Mother nature is angry
America voted Trump and Mother Nature wanted Hilary to win
DAMNIT!
Mother Nature's ANGRY!
Send the Hurricanes! You should have voted for Hillary!
Take this! *pss* *pss*
How fucking dim can you be? My God. How do you end up like this? I don't understand, it blows my mind
"It's hard, especially while promoting this movie, not to...
...not to feel Mother Nature's...
...RAGE, WRATH"
*RASENGAN*
Because hurricanes never happened before. It's hurricane season, and they use it...
to blame
the government
Donald Trump
Oh my God you fucking idiot
You know, bad people in power before, you know
Genghis Khan
Josef Stalin
Adolf Hitler
and then Donald Trump
That's when Mother Nature was like 'Ahh, you know what, that's enough!'
'I've had enough. You have-now you will feel my
WRATH'
I mean...
RAGE
Send in the hurricanes!
I hope no one-I hope no one is woke enough to know why this is happening
Oh shit, Jennifer Lawrence, she's onto me
"Do you find President Trump confusing..."
"I don't find him confusing-I--I...
...I think I know exactly what he is"
Wha-what I find confusing is how someone can use the fact that
people are loosing their homes from the floods and the hurricanes
and you talking about it to further your own political agenda
like hurricanes have never happened before
floods have never happened before
That, to me, is so fucking disgusting...
...when you don't even practice what you preach, you know
Hope I-one day I can become woke as Jennifer Lawrence
Boo hoo hoo, you lost your home?
pfffff
Should have thought twice before you voted, don't you know?
Mother Nature wanted Hillary
I hope everyone who's affected by the flood and the hurricane stays safe
You probably know better than I do and what the fuck to do at these situations. It just sort of annoys me
when I see people using bad...
...tragedies to promote their own thoughts and ideas, and so I wanted to say something about it
That's it from me for now
Squad fam out
*Rage*